before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
one more time
thank you
the last take to Doctor Who review for
the foreseeable future
I've mentioned that I am not going to
have cause to do second visitations to
Dr stuff for a very long time so this
will serve for now at least as the end
of this series which was a continuation
of the overdue Doctor Who reviews where
I took a look at episodes that I had
seen but I had watched prior to having
the channel so I hadn't done review
reviews on them yet
this is uh I guess the end of an era end
of a follow-up to an Era I don't know
but we need to talk about
the power of the doctor
an episode that isn't even all that old
it's less than a year old
but you know what
I was happy to revisit it
I had a lot of fun with this
when it aired I remember thinking I'm
not sure how much scrutiny this holds up
to if any
but I am having fun
and
going in
knowing that
it was going to leave a lot of threads
untied most of them in fact
I actually might have enjoyed this even
more the second time
I enjoyed it pretty well because I kind
of given up on chipnil tying up anything
at that point and I was right to have
that sense but coming in for a second
time and knowing for a fact as opposed
to strongly suspecting
I could kind of just roll with this for
what it is and what it is
a celebration
not only of this era of the doctor but
of previous errors as well with all of
the companions that come back the
multiple classic era doctors who come
back
is it a bit of a cheap trick
yeah
that doesn't mean it doesn't work though
here's the thing I think this is not
only a good finish to a doctor's era it
might even be a great one
it is a true proper celebration of this
era
the only thing
is that what it's celebrating isn't
something that I have always cared for
yet the celebration itself is still
quite good
for lack of a better analogy
it's like going to a really great party
that's being thrown in honor of somebody
you don't actually get along with
but like the party's great and you're
having fun but you also know you'd
probably be having even more fun if you
actually got along with this person
consistently at all
that's basically where I am with this so
when you have things like a shod coming
back or vendor coming back or The
Fugitive doctor for that matter they're
basically only one or a couple of scenes
a piece it's largely fan service they
don't really need to be there for the
sake of the plot in the case of somebody
like a shot like he definitely doesn't
need to be there vendor doesn't do
anything just kind of shows up The
Fugitive doctor was more of a nod than
anything but I enjoy their presence and
I largely because of just the feel
they're they're in the spirit of
remember all the fun we've had across
this series and the only thing that
makes this not work as well as it might
have otherwise is I can look at somebody
like a shot and go right great design
great performance and you kind of wasted
him last time too but that's not really
the fault of this episode if I had
enjoyed more of the Whitaker chiminal
era
this would be almost perfect
now that's in terms of enjoyment and I
do honestly often feel like
final episodes
aren't required to be but for me they do
tend to work well when they are
celebratory it is one of the things
um that I enjoy honestly more about
Journey's End than the end of time part
two because Journey's End felt like more
of a celebration of Russell T Davis era
then end of time did but this feels like
a big celebration of the era
and I just like that
you can argue it's a Victory lap you can
argue all the plot Logistics and stuff
that doesn't make sense or stuff like
how does that even work or why would you
do it that way and
I'm not gonna say that you're wrong to
bring any of that up or that it fits
together neatly it doesn't
I just kind of don't care
and like if you've been following the
series you know that I'm generally not
one to just go ah it doesn't matter as
long as it's fun no if it bugs me it
matters whether it's big or small or
preposterously Petty which I absolutely
can be
but it just all doesn't seem to matter
here
I enjoy this ride
and I think it uses its time well I
think it has a lot of fun it has some
interesting ideas that honestly our
little rush could have been expanded and
or don't make a total amount of sense
but it never lets up and that's the
thing this is the kind of story where if
it slowed down or lost momentum for even
a minute it would all fall apart it is
powered forward on enthusiasm which it
has an abundance
and for me at least that kind of papers
over the flaws going through the thing
we have our cold open reestablishing the
uh Time Lord infused Cybermen that I
think they call themselves The Cyber
Masters and also like setting up for the
exit of Dan which is a little rushed to
be completely honest he does still get
some cute little moments like when he
does the train announcer voice I
actually quite like that everything is
under control and we will be slow into a
gentle stop but then he's just like I
think done and I mean yeah it is a
little rush but I think this final
stretch should be just the doctoring as
honestly a lot more of the show prior to
this should have been just the doctor in
Yaz but better late than never I suppose
we get our old companions coming back
starting with Tegan and Ace now
I adore Ace Ace and seven are one of my
favorite pairings I also really like
Tegan I've come to like Tegan more The
more I've seen of her
um the fifth doctor is not a doctor I've
particularly gotten on well with but
there are good things about his era and
I do think Tegan is one of them so her
attitude especially towards the doctor
how have you been like you can we
discuss this 38 years
pretty well-earned I can be iffy about
the companion seeming
bitter or resentful or like you
abandoned us that kind of thing uh Tegan
yeah no with Tegan she's got good reason
to to hold a fair bit of stuff against
the doctor so it's way more Justified
with her than uh than when it's kind of
been pulled or hinted at in other
instances so that works out okay and
even though I'm not a huge fan of the
fifth doctor her reunion scene with him
it works what I missed you
missed you too
it's good
and if that's good then the scene with
the Seventh Doctor and Ace is phenomenal
we're good oh I'm only good
the race
Ace you know bring up the Nitro 9 the
souped up nitro9 now man like oh well
it's always okay when I blow things up
and it's never found blue stuff up
sometimes sadly it's the only solution
first of all agree with the sentiment
second of all
just the care in his voice
all children leave hoes sooner or later
the joy is to watch them fly and we
don't totally know what it is that went
down between them that's kind of implied
by this direction but
this is just beautiful
and just the general idea of that sort
of liminal space where the doctor hasn't
fully regenerate hasn't fully crossed
over yet where she encounters the first
doctor the fifth the sixth the seventh
the eighth like
it was just a fun group and it was well
done it just shifts between them and
it's it's simple it's straightforward
but it it works even knowing that it's
there when it's not a surprise anymore
when I'm not gonna get a big oh Pop from
it just seeing like
oh I still like this a lot the
Regeneration now that's kicked off by
the master it's a force regeneration now
Dewan is doing what he has done he is
bringing that manic energy to it and
he's still doing it quite well they
bring back sort of the uh hypnotic thing
like just with the eyes that the master
can do uh his love of disguises as he is
passing himself off as Rasputin I think
I had asked when I watched this
originally like wait are they implying
he's always been Rasputin or he took
over Rasputin's life I'm assuming he
took his place because
Master loves disguises this one has done
that uh the
um John Sim Master did that like it's
been reestablished let him have his fun
and you know let him down
the thing is this is the episode that
actually kind of solidified initially
something that I've noted in my re-watch
that I really like about this particular
master and is the one reason I would be
okay with him coming after Missy because
like it's a it's a fairly common debate
amongst fans does this master come after
Missy and if he does doesn't that
undermine her character art because the
Masters just come back to being bad well
here's the thing in my mind with the
self-loathing streak that he very
clearly has solidified for me in that
moment where what he did to the doctors
being reversed and he just says almost
pleading
me that's self-loathing to me can work
with someone who tried to change wanted
to change
but then couldn't
who backslid
who couldn't live up to who they almost
were
self-loathing makes a lot of sense to me
self-loathing isn't really a thing the
master has as a general rule but for a
master following on for Missy who has
slipped back into his worst behaviors
I think self-loathing fits
and it also plasters over some problems
because his plan in many ways is
nonsensical because like he takes over
the doctor's body but like it's still
him
it it looks like him it talks to him it
acts like him you know he goes out in
space and he's like I'm the doctor and I
did this I'm going to ruin the doctor's
reputation like dude the doctor keeps
changing faces you could have just
claimed to be the doctor at any point
like this plan doesn't make sense no
logistically
practically it doesn't
but from the perspective of someone who
is so desperate to be anybody other than
himself
even in a way that is ultimately Skin
Deep
someone who is desperately trying to run
away
from their own
life their own screw-ups
these are the kind of choices made by a
desperate person who can't think of how
else to abandon everything they see is
wrong with themselves
and yeah no it doesn't make a lot of
sense it doesn't need to
the goal is to get out of himself
and this will do that will it fixes
problems no
but
I don't think it matters
he's gonna try whatever he can think of
this is what he thought of this is what
he's trying
and I think if it hadn't been undone if
he quote unquote succeeded he would have
been just as miserable
well then a I don't know ear tops
but he's grasping at whatever he can
if he thinks it'll
free him
from himself
I've come to appreciate dewan's Master
even more on this rewatch and he was
already one of the highlights of this
era for me
so yeah I like him a lot
I did mention there's some somewhat
throwaway stuff that
um honestly could have done with more
fleshing out
a good example of that is the trader
Dalek because the thought process of
this dialect is actually quite
fascinating this idea that it's gone
back to the original original purpose of
the Daleks to preserve the Khaled race
but the dialects aren't the college they
haven't been for a very long time and
they're not ever going to try and
restore themselves to that state
and so by holding on to the original
mission statement is prepared to betray
the rest of the Daleks and that's
pretty interesting that could have been
the starting premise for an entire
episode it's a minor subplot and the
thing gets killed so one could argue
it's a little bit of a waste of the idea
I suppose in some ways analogous to the
Rogue Angel was a really cool idea not
fully utilized and a little bit wasted
in village of the Angels but
kind of like it
I I suppose if you were to give me uh
absolute control I'd say let's pin that
idea let somebody else pick it up later
and do an entire episode with it rather
than get burned off here but it's still
well presented and it's an interesting
idea I I would have liked if more had
been done with it but it is what it is
and I do kind of like it I rather like
the idea of the weird I can't think of
it anything other than the sun tentacle
monster like I like the general idea
that like it's this weird strange
bizarre alien thing that appears as a
child because it will instill the
protective Instinct in uh most things
around it so like that's kind of a cool
idea unto itself it's kind of a cosmic
horror idea except this thing is not uh
particularly dangerous I don't
understand exactly why
at the end the master is able to
redirect its beam that it's destroying
the the Cyber moon with and directed at
the doctor
however there is an aspect to that that
I do like which is the thing is shooting
this destructive Beam at the doctor's
prompting because the doctor told it to
do this so that it could be free
and ultimately that is what is going to
kill her and cause her regeneration
and it is slightly less direct but kind
of in the spirit of the tenth doctor
sacrificing himself for wealth now the
13th doctor didn't know she was gonna
die but
dying as a result of something that she
did or told some someone or something to
do in order to
give it freedom
it's kind of poetic
there's uh the scene with Yaz where it's
just the two of them with the ice cream
I actually really like that scene
I think I kind of liked it before I like
it quite a bit now and it actually
Rhymes extremely well with the scene
from Legend of the sea Devils which was
one of the few like legitimately really
good scenes from that special
whereas before
the doctor was very uh clinging to
things as they were you know not wanting
it to change and in that case
acknowledging potentially her feelings
for Yaz here
she knows she can't cling to it anymore
it's going to end and it's going to end
very soon and there's a shift in tone
despite the scene superficially bearing
a lot of similarities
and they just fit together in a way it
feels like two halves of a conversation
if I do fix myself to somebody
I know sooner or later
it'll hurt a wise person once said to me
goodbye's on the Earth
because what came before was so special
the thing where the doctor just kind of
says I think I need to do this next part
alone I've gone back and forth on it I
think I need to do this next bit alone
I've said in the past that if there was
any Doctor Who was going to say I need
to be alone it was going to be this one
she's been the most distance from her
companions she has uh you know not made
the same strong connections uh with
individuals and she just has been more
isolated so I do buy that
but thinking on it while it works
and I'm not going to say like it fails
as a concept
ultimately I think it would have been
nicer for her not to send Yaz away
because that would have been an arc for
her
because I think the doctor would have
sent her away at pretty much any point
prior to this for her to choose instead
to have her say would have been
more fitting that's not to say yes had
to stay yes could have made the decision
like I can't
like I I don't have it in me to watch
you change it's you said before that the
loss would hurt you this would hurt me
too much like you could find some reason
to still have her not be there and have
the doctor be alone because uh man Dave
Gill didn't sign on for more stuff so
she wasn't going to be the community
going forward you have to remove her one
way or another and thankfully it's not
death or anything like that this time I
still like the support group thing like
it's it it's an excuse just to bring in
a ton of cameos
and I don't care
it's a gorgeous wonderful
thoughtful kind sweet excuse to bring in
a hell of a lot of cameos so that works
for me little throwaway moment there's a
nice line I like from the doctor where
she says
I just I just like that I like that as a
sentiment for her uh and I think that
fits that actually might work as the
best summation for her like she needs to
be busy this is I think part of why she
didn't bond as well with the companions
she can't just settle like the doctor is
Restless energy regardless but this
doctor in particular
has a problem with just being and
always wants something to do always want
something to focus on always want
something to fix
because
then she doesn't have to think too much
about herself
and
normally I can get a little bit just
kind of stating
um like a core feature of a character
like that but
honestly given that I have had trouble
connecting with her at various points
hearing that was nice and I found it
helpful that line didn't jump out at me
the first time it jumped out to me this
time and I think it helps for me to
appreciate
um what her take and her version of the
character was a bit better
um than I have because I I've
gone all over the place uh with my
thoughts on her but
no I like that line
and I very much like how she ends
I like the idea that she wants to see
one last sunrise I like that her big
regret is that she doesn't know what'll
happen next and she wants to find out
and I absolutely adore
it absolutely love it
I'm not really going to talk about the
tenant regeneration I've done complete
separate videos on that as a concept and
I that's not what I want to focus on
here I will have more thoughts on
whether or not that's a good idea when
we actually see those specials in terms
of her actual last words
they're right up there they're some of
the best
as I said this is a really excellent
celebratory
finale for this era
and the only reason that I don't love it
more is that it's celebrating something
that I have a lot of problems with
but
as the Capper and like certainly for
anyone who did enjoy this run more than
I did
I I would imagine like I didn't even
enjoy this run that much I still think
this is great
I can only imagine how hard this hits if
you did enjoy this run
power of the doctor
have you ever watched it lately what'd
you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living take
two Doctor Who reviews are over for the
time being that does mean that there
won't be Wednesday videos for a bit
um but at least not uh as a planned
thing that might pop up because if
something happens mid-week uh timing
wise it might be easier for me to drop
something on a Wednesday then to bump
Saturday stuff I don't know we'll see
but it's not gonna be a regular feature
anymore I have way too much stuff to
catch up on
don't worry too much about that my
schedule any of it what I really want
you to remember
is what I always want you to remember
that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time
tag
you're it
thanks my patreon supporters to make
this possible including Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Linda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 or Nabi likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry caspro
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my bad I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
um